welcome to best life 30 your 30 day
journey to creating the best
life possible for yourself you can just
watch this video or can sign up for
free and get the bonus companion
worksheets that go along with each video
by checking the link
down in the description below all right
today is day 27 and we're gonna learn
how to hire properly
[Music]
you need a team around you to deliver
a lot of idea how do you choose your
team based on what
well i suppose honestly that
it tends to be gut feel more than
anything else
so when i interview somebody
my interview question is always the same
it's just
i said tell me the story of your life
and and the decisions that you made
along the way and why you made them
and then um
if and and also tell me about some of
the most difficult problems you worked
on
and how you solved them and um
that that question i think is very
important because
the people that really solve the problem
they know
exactly how they solved it they know the
little details
and the people that pretended to solve
the problem they can maybe go one level
and then they get stuck i've made
several hiring decisions in the past
which
where i valued uh intellect over heart
and i think that was a mistake and so
i've
tried to try to adjust accordingly
you know that it actually matters
whether somebody is a good person
beyond just you know goodness itself how
have you hired
your team uh and what do you look for
when you bring people on
if you think about it you know i started
the company when i was 19 right so
i can't institutionally believe that
experience is that important
right or else i would have a hard time
reconciling um you know myself
right and and and the company so you
know we
invest in in people who we think are
just
really talented even if they haven't
done that thing before and
you know that applies to people who are
fresh out of university
as well as you know people like um you
know the cfo who took the company public
had not taken a company public before
right and
a lot of his background was in um you
know production uh development at
genentech before so
you know just focus on really talented
people i don't hire people who i
wouldn't work for myself
i think that's a really good heuristic
because everyone knows this like there's
the saying like
a players hire a players and b players
hire c
players which is like good people higher
good yeah um
and i don't think that that's that
informative right because i mean what
are you going to say like just someone
in your organization
better be a player you don't get to hire
people like i mean no i mean um
and i think a lot of the time the
problem is you don't actually know and
sometimes you're like
trying to figure out how good someone is
if you didn't think they were good you
wouldn't have hired them
but the heuristic of only hiring people
who you would work for
um tends to be pretty good i think
because then it's like then that you
know right it's like i would not work
for this person then okay i'm not gonna
like
stretch just because i need to fill a
role today the greatest people are
self-managing they
don't need to be managed you if they
know what if once they know what to do
they'll go figure out how to do it they
don't need to be managed at all what
they need
is a common vision and that's what
leadership
is what leadership is is having a vision
being able to articulate that so the
people around you can understand it
and getting a consensus on a common
vision
we wanted people that were insanely
great at what they did
but we're not necessarily those seasoned
professionals
but who had on at the tips of their
fingers and in their passion
the latest understanding of where
technology was and what we could do with
that technology
and who wanted to bring that to lots of
people so the neatest thing that happens
is when you get a core group
of you know 10 great people that it
becomes
self-policing as to who they led into
that group so i consider the most
important job
of someone like myself is recruiting
agonized over hiring we had interviews i
could go back and look at some of the
interviews again
they would start at 9 or 10 in the
morning and go through dinner
uh a new interviewee would talk to
everybody in the building at least once
and maybe a couple times and then come
back for another round of interviews and
then we'd all get together and talk
about it and then before we fill out an
application
no they never filled out the most
critical part of the interview at least
to my mind was when we finally
decided we liked them enough to show
them the macintosh prototype and then we
sat them down in front of it and if they
just kind of were bored or said this is
a nice computer we didn't want it we
wanted their eyes to light up
and them to get really excited and then
we knew they were one of us
and everybody just wanted to work not
because it was work that had to be done
but it was because something
that we really believed in that was just
going to really make a difference
and that's what kept the whole thing
going we all wanted exactly the same
thing
instead of spending our time arguing
about what the computer should be
we all knew what the computer should be
and we just went and did it we went
through that stage in apple where we
went out and we thought oh we're going
to be a big company let's hire
professional management we went out and
hired a bunch of professional management
it didn't work at all most of them were
bozos they they knew how to manage but
they didn't know how to do anything
and so what if you're a great person why
do you want to work for somebody you
can't learn anything from
uh and you know what's interesting you
know who the best managers are
they're the great individual
contributors who never
ever want to be a manager but decide
they have to be a manager
because all every no one else is going
to be able to do as good a job as them
what i found out the accountants and
attorneys who went to the bigger schools
are not the best i have found what i'm
looking for
is somebody who may be a private guy who
is
passionate about entrepreneurship so
they're a great
attorney for entrepreneurs
you know they're not you know most
attorneys looking for the big client
like i want to work for
you know general electric what i want is
the attorney and the account who are
passionate about it being entrepreneurs
so my my guys right here in phoenix are
entrepreneurs and my
accountants are entrepreneurs every time
i hire the big name
corporate and law accounting firms i
have been grossly
overpaid and underserved because they're
so
used to doing bigger things they don't
have time for a little guy like me
it's the same with bankers i'm looking
for a banker who loves being an
entrepreneur
you know you got to have this
partnership with the bank you know i i
dump on the financial services industry
a lot
and they deserve to be dumped on but
you've got to have one on your team you
know so my banker is the love of my life
because that's where i get my money from
to me love is very important i i look
for
someone who loves the company who loves
a vision that you're casting i'm casting
love's a crusade that
that their heart starts connecting with
it because
if if you can hire my experience has
been if you can hire people based on
love you don't need to have work ethic
on a list because
love is an action in my opinion if love
is an action and the definition of love
to you is also an action
it's a verb then that means everything
from love work ethic comes because of
love so if someone loves they're gonna
have a work ethic if parents
make food for their kids three meals a
day not because they have to but because
they love and they put the time to cook
if
you know parents put the time to drop
off the kids in the morning and pick
them up and work so hard and do this and
do that
love it doesn't there's no manual that
says you got to work hard when you're a
parent no
the manual is you love they have a place
in your heart so you work so i hire
based on love so
and another thing with love is this is
what to keep in mind i don't
i you can't force somebody to love
you your vision your company you can't
do it and if you
constantly are trying to force somebody
to love you it's kind of like the guy
who's in love with this girl and he
loves her so much but she doesn't love
him she likes him
and you know she tolerates him and all
his life he's trying to earn her love
and she's just not going to love him she
doesn't love him she just likes him
you know they're just together because
it's good they don't this guy has
all his life and that can be very
draining
i i don't hire for forcing somebody to
love if you love it we're gonna work
together if you don't
no problem you're going to find a place
that you're going to love and we're
going to find people that we're going to
hire that we're going to love as well
that's okay
as a interview question because we
obviously can't tell people what we're
doing so we want something that has
artificial intelligence maybe has some
comms problems with it
it has to really have these meaty hard
like get dirty in the world kind of
stuff because all the things that we do
have those characteristics
i have often asked people a question
about let's say that we have
robotic moles and we're sending them out
in the world they're supposed to go find
gold and bring it back to us and then
just engage them in a conversation about
like
how would we do gold detection um how
far do you think one of those moles
could dig before it had to come back and
get
power do you think it'd be realistic to
like put a tether on it so that it
wouldn't run out of power
you know should we have conveyor belts
like out its butt so that it could like
send the gold back
just keep digging you know what would
happen if that mole like went like
under you know the ground into canada or
mexico like if one of the moles goes
rogue you know what are we going to do
and you very quickly get
into this state where you find out who's
going to go with you on these journeys
because some people just kind of short
circuit and minute two of the questions
they're just like
i know just and then the interview
the interview often is is over they
don't know it yet for another 28 minutes
but some people are super excited and
they're like wait
i actually think we could do that and
you know it's probably we shouldn't be
making moles
going digging for gold we aren't don't
get excited but
but if you find one please return it yes
but the people don't take the gold out
of its mouth exactly oh they don't like
that
but the people who will engage in that
conversation
that's a good sign everybody wants to
know who to hire and what i look for
and obviously i look for someone that's
humble and i look for someone that's
balanced
and really you know it's one of those
things where
as much as you can before you hire
someone get to know them
and the advice we give people an echelon
front all the time when they're looking
to hire someone is we say look
if you can hire them temporarily bring
them on as a contractor for 90 days
you have to see them in the environment
that they're actually going into
they're going to be working in before
you know what they're really going to be
like
because just like going through they
screen people like
crazy to go into seal training and they
can't tell who's gonna make it and who's
not gonna make it they just can't tell
and they you you work with people in the
seal teams
and you think you know what they're
gonna be like when you go into combat
but you just can't tell you can have a
decent idea but you just can't tell
and so if you get the opportunity or the
best way to do it is try and bring
people on board
in a temporary manner so you get to know
them better and then once you know them
you can either hire them or you can get
rid of them easily when someone comes to
look for a job
with us they'll say well
i gotta make money so great what's the
pay salary job whatever
that stuff that's the bar then the next
bar
is who am i gonna be working with and if
you're working with
eight players then you pass to the next
test and the final test is
is this a mission that i care about do i
really want to wake up every morning
and and and really put my all in if you
can have
all three of those if you can do you can
be paid properly or play competitively
it's not not necessarily paid more just
competitively if you can
be surrounded by eight players and you
have a mission
that you care about you you will have
people
lining up to work to work for you and
then that flows to where the customer is
you'll have customers lining up to to
buy a product or use your use your brand
the people you hire define the culture
whether you like it or not so larry and
sergey when they started the company
said we need to have really smart people
so they hired a rocket scientist
and they hired a medical doctor and they
hired a stanford graduate who had been a
professional football player
because they figured that they wanted
normal people who'd done something
exceptional
so in my case i was a pilot and i had
done other things and they said okay
you're good enough
you know the ceo has to have something
besides being a ceo
that makes them interesting and everyone
had something i would go around and i'd
say well
what's special about you it's like it's
like sesame street you know what's
special about you and what's special
about you but there was always an
interesting story
so another lesson i learned is that you
don't hire generic people you hire
people
who've had some kind of uh of stress or
achievement or whatever
the best people hire by the way are cfos
who've gone bankrupt
because boy have they been through the
war and on the cfo's
on the cfo side and the finance side you
want somebody who's
not going to happen again and you only
go bankrupt once by the way
i think the second thing is you have to
hire big and big
i don't mean famous i mean ahead of
where you are
so when you're growing an organization
really quickly what happens is that
what normally takes an organization
years happens in a period of just months
so when i was at google you know my team
went from four
to four thousand in about five years
that means that if you look at those
first four people i hired
in order for them to be part of the
people who are running that organization
they need to do about you know 10 or 15
years worth of growing
and you know getting experience in a
much shorter period of time
so if you think you're going to grow
quickly hire for what you think you're
gonna need
over hire hire people who are more
qualified have more experience
or hire people who are right out of
school but
can overachieve in their current roles i
don't think it's that number of years in
the workforce that matters
i think it's hiring the people that
you're going to need then
now because then happens so quickly
we look for compliance and willingness
before intelligence
um so you don't look for skill you look
for someone who's
i don't look for potential i never look
for potential
what do you look for then just like yes
i'm willing to look we hired the way the
patriots do
right you know they don't hire the best
guys
right they never do
they get all the rings though they do
okay there's three people in charge on
that team
there's not 33 it is a dictator
there's a dictator on that team but if
you study all sports i mean it's pretty
much like that too
you know i mean portland portland
doesn't really have that you know
he leaves curry alone and he leaves you
know um
durant durant alone and they're doing
good you know that means it's a
different style
right but but um but somebody those are
with superstars yeah
man it's got to be so hard yeah because
everyone's got a personality and you've
got the opinion
yeah but so let's see how long that
legacy can last what are they three
years now
yeah so you know good area let's see if
they tear themselves apart
but i know that new england patriots
thing works consistently there's an
owner
he's not involved he's just a coach
this guy bill runs the deal yeah
and then and then bill gives the ball to
brady and says a good
deal yeah you know so uh they hire they
they they they hire from the
lower half of the draft they don't
overpay for anybody
and if and if you don't comply you're
looking off the team they're going to
win without a great person
i like that i'm going to give you one
quick system this is a system that
involves people
great one of the most valuable things
that i've ever done just used it
recently with
with great success really really helped
me out
i called the daily update right you hire
a new person you sit them down on day
one
and you say tony we're going to be
working together really excited about
working with you
i'd like you to do one thing for me at
the end of every work day
i'd like you to send me a daily update
send it to me my email it should take
you five minutes to do 10 minutes
max if it takes you more than five to
ten minutes you're doing something wrong
right
in the daily update i want you to tell
me three things number one
what i did today results i got right
number two
problems or challenges that you know
came up number three
questions that i have for you okay so
what i did today results i got problems
and challenges
questions right if you will watch
someone's daily updates
every day for 30 days you will learn so
much about them
that people have known them for years
don't even realize because you will see
the pattern right
are they results driven are they
activity driven do they even you know
notice the difference in their life
noticing whether or not they're really
even asking any new questions whether
they're getting curious about things in
any new way shape or form
what is perceived by them to be a
problem versus exactly will they
ask you if they have a problem you know
what's what's going on um
it's really great even even more
importantly do they send it to you every
day
right that's the rule really okay
because you're absolutely right
when you get to the end of the first 30
days and you got 12 of them or six or
exactly there there are a couple of
scenarios one is they sent it every day
but it's bad news yeah once they send it
every day and it's good news another is
they sit didn't send it every day that's
bad news and others they you know did
videos whatever so they're kind of these
options if you've got someone that's
performing
it actually doesn't matter whether they
sent them every day or not because
they're um they're a performer
yeah if there's a superstar and they
didn't send the daily update every day
you can say
we're going to get you an assistant
that's going to send your updates every
day okay
fine just tell them and maybe you can
coach them or whatever right but if
they're not performing
and they're not sending daily updates or
they're not performing and sending
you'll see it
and i mean in my experience the under
performance they usually don't send the
update every day
and then when you sit down with them at
the end of 30 days you can just say look
i asked you to do one thing consistently
for this 30 days
right i ask you to do one thing and
which just send me a little daily update
and they'll have excuses or whatever
will come up
you say i just don't feel like this is
going to be a good fit because we need
results and accountability and
communication and it's just not your
style to do that
right you know you're not then it then
it kind of works out for everybody you
know what's in everybody's best interest
so the daily update has been
tremendously valuable the trick is
and it sounds facetious sometimes but
it's not you hire
great people great actors and actresses
and then you get out of their way you
don't
play the director you don't hover over
them
you let them change your lines you let
them make up their own contributions and
do things
because the people that i've worked with
have had careers and are famous and a
great before they met me
and they're great in my movies and
they're great after they leave me
so nothing special is happening if you
just
hire wonderful people
that's all you have to do and just don't
mess them up
don't ruin them and you know it's really
a very simple thing then you get credit
for directing them and everyone says
well
you did such a great job so but it isn't
you're just not screwing them up that's
all
bill gates was asked what was the
winning formula
of microsoft when microsoft was really
the heavyweight champion of
their industry i think they're a little
lost right now
but the larger point again is he
replied with this what made
microsoft microsoft was not our software
what made microsoft microsoft
was our hiring i just want to suggest to
you the second
point or trait of a world-class
company is their ability to hire a
players here is the brain tattoo i want
you to absolutely hardwire
in to your business philosophy as a
leader
you cannot build an a level company
with c level talent if your company is
not winning
in your field right now you likely have
weaknesses in your hiring
don't just hire people because it's the
easiest move
to make a lot of companies spend
very little time on hiring and then most
of
their time managing their hiring
mistakes and you know if you're building
a business if you're an entrepreneur if
your manager
if you're a ceo like a lot of the people
who watch these mastery sessions
and come to my live events you know i'm
speaking truth
here so you really want to nail your
hiring
next recommendation is that you hire
infected people
i think that
and a an infected founding team
is probably more important than a
founding team that on paper
has a good background in work experience
or education
that that you know that people who love
the product or service
that's more important than their degrees
it's more important than their work
experience
focus on the people who love the product
or service
this means fundamentally you ignore
what's irrelevant
and in many cases education and work
experience is irrelevant
this is completely contrary to what most
vcs will tell you if you have vcs
further on into this
course and if you ask them well what are
you looking for they're going to tell
you and i'll tell you that right now you
can skip that lecture they're going to
say
we want proven teams with proven
technology and proven traction
in other words we want people who have
founded cisco
won a nobel prize and they're doing 50
million dollars in revenue that's an
early stage deal for a vc today
all right by contrast garage is in a
different business we want unproven
teams unproven traction
and unproven technologies completely
different world
the irrelevant thing is that
you know think about what an
entrepreneur has to go through so let's
take
let's take what might seem very
attractive to many venture capitalists
let's say that on your founding team is
someone who was a senior vice president
at microsoft
most vcs would salivate at the thought
this is a
proven executive this executive has been
with microsoft for 10 years
has helped microsoft grow etc etc but if
you
peel the layers of the onion one level
lower you would see that that executive
during his or her career at microsoft
had on average a war chest of 50 billion
dollars in microsoft
during that time frame they had a market
uh market share percentage of roughly
95 percent during that person's tenure
at microsoft
that person's greatest fear was the
antitrust division of the us department
of justice
now you're going to take that proven
executive from microsoft
and stick them in a garage with five
hundred thousand dollars
zero brand awareness zero market share i
would
make the case that that might not be the
ideal higher for you
okay now you may be wondering why in the
world are there
diamond rings in this picture it is
because i am living proof of this
theory i graduated from stanford in a
psych degree as i told you
i attended uc davis law school and when
you say you attended a school it means
you didn't finish
i attended two weeks so i really in fact
i never got started actually
and and after that um
i went into the jewelry business i i
enrolled the following year in an mba
program at ucla and while i was there i
started working in the jewelry business
my first job was literally counting
diamonds
so on paper if you were apple computers
you know recruiter you said alright so
we need someone to go out and to
convince the most technical audience we
have
software developers why they should
write macintosh software
i don't think the spec would say psych
degree
law school dropout marketing mba
currently counting diamonds in los
angeles
you know that might not be the sweet
spot
okay but what enabled me to be
successful with macintosh is i
loved macintosh the scales were removed
from my eyes the first time i saw it
you know the clouds parted the angels
started playing their trumpets it was a
religious experience for me
that's why i succeeded because it ain't
because of my psych degree
and it's not because i attended law
school for two weeks and it's not
because i have
a marketing degree from ucla all right
ignore the irrelevant
what is relevant is they love the
product
second point you should hire better than
yourself
very difficult for most founders
particularly engineering types who
believe that because of their superior
chip speed that they should be the best
sales person the best finance person the
best marketing person
and the best engineering person you need
to hire people better than you a
players by definition higher a players
b players hire c players and c players
hire
d players so pretty soon you'll be
surrounded by
z players okay that's what's called the
bozo explosion
[Music]
and what follows the bozo explosion is
the layoff
okay so avoid the bozo explosion
the third thing is to apply the stanford
shopping center test
the way this works is suppose you're at
stanford shopping center you see someone
who is being recruited by your company
who's interviewing at your company
the distance between you and the person
when you first see him or her is from me
to the back of the room that person up
there has not yet seen me but i have
seen them
or him or her so at this point i have
this
sort of choices i can rush over and say
hi how are you i know you're
interviewing can i tell you more about
the company
i really think you should join our
company we're just going to kick some
ass we're going to make meaning we're
going to change the world with our
technology
or you can say stanford shopping center
isn't that big
maybe i'll bump into them if i do i'll
say hello if i don't
i won't say hello the third reaction is
i'm gonna get in my car and go to valco
shopping center
okay if your reaction to the job
candidate is not i'm gonna
run over there and say hello to the
person don't hire
a person because when you're creating a
startup it is a family
it is a dysfunctional family honestly
but it is a family
if you don't feel the compulsion to run
over there and say hello
probably not the right person now i've
got a really special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the best
live 30 questions of the day it's not
enough to just watch a video you have to
do something about it so pull out your
worksheets
and if you don't have the worksheets you
can get them for free using the link in
the description below
here we go question number one what
change do you need to make to your
hiring process
number two who around you are not the
right people that you need
and number three how will you move on
from them and bring in
a players and if you're doing the best
live 30 challenge with me i want to
celebrate you give me a hashtag
bestlife30 down in the comments below
you will never accomplish your business
goals without a team
you have big goals big dreams big
ambitions it will never
happen as a solo entrepreneur you need
to get out of the mindset that you can
do everything yourself
you can't you can go fast you can stay
small
be nimble and being a solo person and
you still may always
be the most powerful and an important
individual in your company
but you need to build a team you need to
scale up and you need to get over your
fears
and hire properly so i think a big
reason why most entrepreneurs don't end
up building successful teams
because they get burned because you
don't know how to hire properly because
you hire somebody
you think this is great this person is
going to take over all of these things
that i don't want to do they're going to
solve my problems and then you can go on
to build bigger things for your business
the problem is that person that first
person
rarely works out the first person that
you hire very rarely works out
in the business very rarely look at
companies and look at their success and
look at who employee number one two
three
eight ten was and see are they still
around in the company
very rarely does it work out most of the
time it's because
you don't know what you're doing because
you don't know how to hire and so you
hire the wrong person
i'm going to give you a process that i
go through that i think will really help
you
you can learn from my success you have
24 people on my team and i want to
shortcut the path for you because i
think the hiring process is broken
what do most people do when they hire
most people they do some kind of job ad
they post it
then you do this long interview process
right you're reading through
resumes and cover letters you bring them
in for an interview and then you get
down to the one person you end up hiring
them
and what ends up happening a lot of
times that person doesn't work out
or they're just okay but you don't want
to
fire them because you don't want to go
through that entire painful process
again to find somebody new
it's too painful it sucks you don't want
to do it again here's how you flip the
script
one when you're doing a job posting you
you make it one
big ugly paragraph this is what i do a
job posting is one big
ugly nasty paragraph why because i want
people to be detail-oriented i want
people to read the whole thing
i don't want to make it easy because a
lot of times the job's not going to be
easy
right so one big ugly paragraph in the
middle of that big ugly paragraph will
be some skill testing question
it'll be something like tell me how many
subscribers i have on my youtube channel
okay tell me how many followers i have
on twitter and put it in the first line
of your application
eighty percent of people won't do it
eighty percent
of people who apply to a job will not
answer the skill testing question
why because they didn't even read the
application
they didn't read it they just saw the
title i'm looking for a video editor i'm
looking for an online marketer i'm
looking for
xyz and they hit submit and they send it
to you now you're going to spend time
reading their cover letter
reading their resume going through their
work history but they spent
five seconds on you you're gonna spend
five minutes ten minutes on each of them
and they spent five seconds on you times
up by a hundred applicants
that's a lot of wasted hours no wonder
why you don't want to go on through that
process again
it sucks eighty percent of people will
not read the job description you need to
filter them out
five percent of people then say great
tell me what your twitter account is and
i'll tell you how many followers you
have
go to twitter type in evan carmichael
you can find me right
you need to have a little bit of
resourcefulness if you want to work for
an entrepreneur so already 85
of the people are eliminated they're
gone
now i only have to read through 15 of
the applications that come through
this is a lot better right these are the
people who put in the time who read the
application
and they want to work with you right
let's talk about that job posting
what's in that big ugly paragraph so you
want to leave with the values what are
you staying for what are you all about
even in the job title right away i'm
looking for a video
marketer that believes in entrepreneurs
and then talk about what my company's
all about what my mission is what i'm
trying to accomplish
right before getting to the the job
description and the roles and
responsibilities
i want to leave with the mission because
somebody's going to look at that and say
this is the stupidest thing i've ever
seen amazing don't apply
or they'll say i love this finally
i want to work extra hard to apply for
that company right the people who are
good fits for you
from a values and culture point of view
they will self-select in
that's what you want so don't just tell
me in your job at what the roles and
responsibilities are
lead with the mission so leave with the
mission leave with the values
tell me what what your company is trying
to do then you have your skill testing
question
and then you tell me what the job
description's all about like what am i
going to be doing on a day-to-day basis
what's my role what do you want me to do
every day for you right
and then i'll at the end put some kind
of qualitative question in
as well so the skill testing question is
how many followers do i have
the qualitative one would be tell me
about
who your favorite entrepreneur is and
why i don't really care what their
answer is some people say
richard branson or elon musk or some big
name some people will say
my dad because he started his own little
grocery store
right i don't really care what the
answer is i just want to see if they
actually care because if you're working
for me
i want you to actually care about
entrepreneurs that's the mission that
we're on
right right after that you still get a
whole bunch of people who will apply
next what most people do is go to a job
interview i think a job interview is a
giant waste of time
i think most people hire from a job
interview and it doesn't actually test
for the skills that you're trying to
hire
right so if i'm looking for a video
editor as an example right i'm looking
for new video editors for my channel
how well they do in a job interview
doesn't translate doesn't map to their
success
as a video editor right maybe they're
super nervous when they're talking to
people
maybe they're really shy maybe they
can't articulate themselves
via voice very well right and so if i'm
judging their abilities
based off of how they communicate face
to face that's not what i'm trying to
hire for now if i'm hiring a sales
person
that's a different story right they can
sell me on on themselves they need to be
good
face-to-face but for video editor it's
the wrong skill set
and so i think people hire off of a job
interview which tests the wrong skills
so the best thing you can do is go on a
trial so anybody who
answers my job at and will give me the
skill testing question
and then tell me who their favorite
entrepreneur is and why i'll then hire
them on a trial
i'll give them five paid hours
no job interview five paid hours for a
job that i think will take them two
now why do i do this i'm not a micro
manager
i don't want to micromanage people it
drives me nuts i don't want to be on
your shoulder and say hey did you get
this done did you get that done
it's not my style so i need people who
will self-manage
and people who won't milk me so
i'll pay you for up to five hours for a
job that i think should take you to
and here's what i'm looking for one if
you took the full five hours
either one you're milking me
right you should have done it a lot
faster but you know you can get five
hours so
you're gonna say it took you five hours
amazing that's a cheap
way to test if somebody's a good fit for
you or not or two they're just really
slow and incompetent
either way you don't want to have that
person on your team so i want the person
who's gonna come in at five so i want
the person who's going to say
hey i know i can have five hours but
it's only actually gonna take me two
so let me do it in two that's the person
i want on my team
from there what i'm looking for is
somebody who goes above and beyond the
call of duty
so somebody who doesn't just do the
thing that i ask for
but injects their own style tries to
find a way to make it better
so the video editor is a great example
when i went through my video editing
uh hiring process i hired maybe 20
people on a trial
15 20 people on a trial something like
that paid trial up to five hours
christina who's been my editor for the
past i don't know six years
she came in and said hey evan here's
what you asked for i had a very clear
requirement here's what i want you to do
here's what you asked for
but what you did kind of sucks and
here's how i would do it
and she made something that was better
right so she gave me what i asked for
and then went above and beyond to give
me something better
that's the person i want to hire right
and that's the person i want to keep on
my team
and that's why she's been with me for
six
or so years right so that process
is how you find great people and in that
process of actually working with them on
a project
if you are working for me to be a video
editor i want to see how well you edit a
video not how well you
respond to an interview question not how
well you can write a cover letter
or a resume it's testing for the wrong
skills
and so that's the process and that saves
time and it brings the right people in
and it allows you to scale and leverage
your business so that you are not doing
everything yourself because you have an
important mission
you're trying to help people but you
can't do everything yourself
you need to get out of that mindset you
need to stop doing everything yourself
you need to start by bringing on people
even part-time
the first person to hire us for one hour
a day that's it
bring people on part-time to free up
your time
get people who are better than you at
that thing free up your time to focus on
the things that you have michael jordan
level talent at
and that's how you start to scale it may
not work out the first time it may not
work out the second time
don't quit on building a team because
everybody who's done the thing that you
want to do
all your heroes all of your mentors
everybody you look up to they built the
team
and you need to too if you want to join
the best life 30 challenge click the
link right here below me or if you want
more videos on how to hire effectively
check the playlist right there next to
me
continue to believe and i'll see you
there